Robert rice in your new book the work of
Nations on page 95 you write as stated
earlier by most official measures
America's 500 largest industrial
companies failed to create a single net
new job between 1975 and 1990 their
share of the civilian labor dropping
from 17 percent to less than 10 percent
why is that happening well a number of
reasons Brian American corporations are
changing their shape you know in the
1950s about the top 500 American
corporations were responsible for 1/2 of
the gross national product in the United
States and about a quarter of the gross
national product of the entire world a
free world but they were organized like
pyramids few people at the top making
all the decisions huge numbers of people
down below walking in lockstep the
philosophy of production was high volume
standardized stable mass production that
was a economies of scale and it worked
like a like a charm in the 1950s 1960s
but then about the mid 1970s - things
begin to happen 1 the American market
becomes saturated for high-volume
standardized stable commodities the
whole post-war pent-up demand new family
formation you get repeat purchases but
you don't get the same big increase in
purchases every standard washing machine
your standard car secondly you have
global competition new technologies of
transportation communication cargo ships
container ships satellite communications
technologies allow that hold high volume
standardized stable mass production
process to be fragmented hustled out
wherever around the globe it could be
done most cheaply and that meant that
for the first time there was no longer
any particular advantage in doing mass
production in the United the United
States so there's big colossal
corporations based on economies of scale
became endangered species by the late
1970s we heard Ronald Reagan during the
80s say many times during my
administration we've created 16 17
million jobs in this country if those
large corporations haven't added any
jobs were they coming from well many of
them are coming from small businesses
but be a little care
the debate between big business and
small business is complicated much more
complicated than people give it credit
for because a lot of big businesses are
becoming in a sense Federation's of
small businesses they're their
decentralizing into decentralized
business units where they're farming out
some contracting more and more of their
work to smaller businesses so to simply
say small businesses are creating all
the jobs misses the big picture which is
these still have these big groups of
companies it's more accurate actually to
say that American business small
businesses are evolving into
Confederations of small businesses large
businesses are decentralizing into
Confederations of small businesses
what's a small business what's a large
business well it this doesn't really
matter any longer but there's something
in between the two where do you live I
live in Cambridge Massachusetts what do
you do I spend my time writing lecturing
I teach at the John F Kennedy School of
Government at Harvard University I
consider myself primarily in my books my
writing my lecturing my consulting I do
quite a lot of consulting for government
agencies and for and for companies and
above all in my teaching I'm an educator
am i my goal in life my function in life
is to take a look at reality to research
it to talk to a lot of people and then
to teach what I see and hopefully it
provokes people it makes them see
reality a little bit differently where
are you born
Scranton Pennsylvania wonderful town
don't remember it at all I left there
when I was about six months old and
moved to upstate New York little farming
community my neighbors were all farmers
father had a little software soft goods
store you know a little ladies dress
shop but there was an old farmer down
the street where I know who I used to
business five six years old used to sit
on his lap we talk politics that's where
I got my political education years later
I learned that his name was Henry
Wallace for vice president the United
States how did you have access to Henry
Wallace he was a farmer down the street
and at what age did you start talking to
five how did you have access to it well
it wasn't very difficult I walked down
the street with my mom
and she knew him and farmer Henry and I
struck up a conversation in a friendship
and from that point on until I was about
10 I'd walk down the street sit on his
porch and we talked not difficult you
know we farming you don't have to have
access to people you're just a farm farm
down the road how long did you know
Henry walls well let's see he must have
died when I was maybe 10 11 12 years old
something like that I have only a dim
recollection of him but we had great
conversations about American politics
about farms about where the country was
going do you remember anything about
what he told you he talked a little bit
about Roosevelt I mean I do remember him
talking about Roosevelt I remember him
talking to me about history I must have
been about seven eight nine years old in
grammar school talked about the Second
World War didn't talk about I don't
remember anything about Truman and again
I had no idea in those days that he had
been vice president of the United States
to me he was just a lovely old kind
gentleman sitting on a porch okay what's
next I mean that was rather unusual for
somebody your age what did you go
where'd you go school I went to local
public grammar school local public high
school again very small this is a real
farm community and then I went on to
Dartmouth College and over New Hampshire
after that I went to Yale Law School and
was fortunate enough to win a Rhodes
Scholarship with Oxford University
studied economics and then I decided I
had enough of degrees I was about 50
years old by then and had to get on with
life go back to Henry Wallace and right
after that do you you point to any other
factor that got you interested enough
and learning that you did that well to
get into Dartmouth oh I had some
brilliant teachers inspiring teachers
even a small farm country
school in those days it's a big
difference between now and then you know
in those days a lot of very talented
women went into teaching they didn't
have many other alternatives and these
days if we want talented women or men in
teaching they do have many many other
alternatives we don't you know we didn't
have to pay our teachers very much in
those
we had a free ride on the fact that
talented women didn't have all those
other alternatives these days if we want
down with the people to go into teaching
where we are we are going to have to pay
them unfortunately as I point out in the
book we're really only paying our
teachers these days only four percent
more in inflation-adjusted terms than we
paid them in 1970 even though supply and
demand has changed considerably
this year the average West German former
West German teacher in the former West
German schools is earning 51 thousand
dollars grammar school teacher we pay
our teacher than half that why do you
think it's the case well teaching again
has not been a terribly high status
professional talking about K through 12
I think in large part because women
dominated it we kind of assumed it was
it was women's work there's little
sexism implied it was never the high
status occupation that it has become and
it has been for many many years in
Europe and also in Japan that's one of
our problems I think instead of putting
the teacher on the pedestal we tend to
just poopoo teaching we tend to assume
that it's just going to be there there
will always be teachers that's not the
case you're a liberal well Brian I don't
I'm getting so confused these days I'm
not even sure what liberal means any
longer I'm certainly not a protectionist
I own a servant I'm a free-market here
I'm not a conservative although I got
very worried because the Wall Street
Journal Fortune magazine they loved my
book so that I must be doing something
wrong where do you think you started
thinking like you think today well at
what point in your life did you remember
well there's a theory that people reach
political consciousness that stays with
them for the rest of their lives when
they're about 17 18 years old that is
that's the point at which your your
basic ideas about American economics and
politics get formulated they may change
a little bit after that time but that's
that's your that's your fundamentals in
college I went to work for Robert
Kennedy as an intern here on there on
the hill didn't work very close to him I
was in charge of the signature machine
for the summer you know you put in the
letters and it says a Robert F Kennedy
in fact I used to type letters to my
friends dear mr. Dworkin congratulations
on having the largest nose
gesture counter in Robert the F Canada
he still has it on the wall but I was
close enough that I was I was struck by
by Bob Kennedy what he wanted to do one
day I remember I I came out of my the
signature machine place I was getting a
little delirious with all those
signatures and he was coming out of the
elevator now I had not met him there
were a lot of other kids working for him
at the time and he looked at me and he
said how are you doing Bob it's good to
have you here with us I thought to
myself knew my name and I sailed I was
three feet off the floor I went back to
the signature machine I was so delighted
to do those signatures but he was an
inspiring man and the people around him
were very inspiring and I got caught up
in that and I suppose you might say that
that was the beginning of my genuine
political involvement and and commitment
how did you get that internship
I got the internship because let's see
Kennedy's a a in those days it was Jo
Dolan if I wrote Carol had interviews
with kids in Westchester Putnam northern
New York State and I wanted to go down
there I was a college sophomore at the
time and I I went in to talk to Joe
Dolan and obviously I must have said the
right thing I don't know how else he
would have selected me but he selected
me that was what about 1966 that it must
have bidding it must have been 66 must
have been about 1966 right it was the
Vietnam War was just beginning and I
remember the the intern who worked for a
Jacob Javits at the time it was Mark
Greene who is now Consumer Affairs
director in New York City mark and I
contrived to get all of the interns
working on the hill to sign an anti-war
petition and it was a very big deal I
mean we had hundreds and hundreds of
signatures we got almost everybody Bob
Kennedy invited me into his office
toward the end of the summer just when
the signature drive was really really in
full full force I had not seen him since
he came out of the elevator that day he
said to me I understand you're one of
the organizers of this anti-war petition
I said that's right he said cease then
what what do you mean he said I'm having
enough trouble with Lyndon Johnson right
now I don't need it
gotta get out to the media that my
intern is organizing this anti-war
petition so I ceased another lesson in
American politics you were at Dartmouth
I want to ask you about the three
institutions where you went to school
Dartmouth what impact did that leave on
you well Dartmouth College is oh is
probably the best undergraduate liberal
arts education in America it was clearly
that in the 1960s it clearly is in the
1990s very dedicated teachers small
classes and not a university not a lot
of graduate programs but really a
tremendous emphasis on liberal arts and
I had some of the best teaching I have
ever had anywhere at Dartmouth it gave
me a love for learning I think I had
that from high school days anyway I
happened as I said before I was
fortunate enough to have enormously
it's how I didn't gifted school teachers
but Dartmouth opened my eyes to history
to politics to economics to ancient
Greece literature it was a very
wide-ranging liberal arts education Yale
Law School I went to Yale Law School at
a time
when people went to Yale Law School not
to learn the law but because that was a
center of social activism and thought
about changes in the country
unfortunately when I got there I
realized it really was a law school in
fact most people graduated Yale Law
School and actually went to work the
corporate law firms I didn't want to do
that I enjoyed Yale Law School I did
learn a great deal one of my teachers
there was Bob book and when he became
Solicitor General here in Washington he
invited me down to be his assistant
years later so my first job a lot of
people don't realize this you know I'm a
liberal but my first job in the Ford
administration was as one of Robert
Bork's assistants what'd you learn from
him he has at least did that I haven't
seen him in years he had a wonderful
sense of humor
he was great to work for he and I did
not see eye to eye on men
the issues of the day I had to brief and
argue Supreme Court cases taking
positions many of which I did not agree
with I wasn't very good at the job
anyway I really wasn't cut out to be
that kind of a lawyer but I learned
about him as I learned about the human
side of him which is something that a
lot of people don't know did he get a
bad deal when he wasn't confirmed by the
Senate well I think that he got a bad
deal in the sense that I think he was
treated very roughly I'm gonna say
something that's probably not very kind
and but I think it needs to be said I
don't think he was temperamentally or
his temperamentally suited I personally
even though I worked for him even though
I could think very highly of him I don't
think I'd like to see him on the high
court so I think that the the actual
decision was probably right the process
I think he was badly hurt by it were you
working for him when he became Attorney
General acted I no no I came after that
I came what he was a Solicitor General
was was that in that way much you know I
had only had to be sisters you know that
he became because that was the third
person around your apps you're
absolutely right okay I was not working
there when he became Attorney General I
was there when he was Solicitor General
I went over to the Federal Trade
Commission I worked for at first none of
the Republicans and then under Jimmy
Carter I became director of policy
planning for the Federal Trade
Commission which actually in terms of
the book is a very important step
because most of my concerns most of my
insights about the gradual
competitiveness problems of America
began when I was working at the Federal
Trade Commission in the mid 1970s those
were days nobody was talking very much
about American competitiveness in those
days but after going through industry by
industry an awful lot of data about many
American industries it became painfully
clear to me that there was indeed a
competitiveness problem what was the
impact of Oxford on you and how did you
get there how'd you get how do you get
how do you get a road school I don't
know there's no formula for getting a
Rhodes Scholar they say you have to be
genius and an athlete I was neither of
those so was it was a fluke why I got a
road scholarship the best well Oxford is
another world I don't know if you've
been there Brian or any
a watching has been there it's an
idyllic world it really is a
nineteenth-century world it has
absolutely nothing to do with the 20th
century I had been very actively
involved in American politics for a few
years Robert Kennedy had been shot
I was very disillusioned with American
politics I needed a break I'm still a
kid I was shaken by all of the stuff
that was going on in America and Oxford
was a wonderful place to retreat to I
had a marvelous two years did a lot of
acting and directing met my wife British
woman in fact met her the first day we
were both at Oxford she was a student
coming up to Oxford they were both there
waiting for an audition for a student
play I didn't want to be a typical
forward American an aggressive American
asking her her name so she left I left
and then I figured that I had blown it
because he was a wonderful intelligent
woman and she would probably go off into
the atmosphere doubtful that we would
both get parts in the play and I'd never
see her again so I had an idea the best
idea that I've ever had before or since
I got my college at Oxford to allow me
to direct my own play and I put up
audition signs all over Oxford
announcing that there would be auditions
for the play hoping against hope that
she would arrive at my auditions and she
did and I cast her as the leading lady
but she's been ever since what did she
do now she's a lawyer she actually she
teaches law at a northeastern a law
school kids sorry kids two kids two boys
how old 7 and 10 and in the sigh and the
opening of the book here you have a
dedication to the memory of Frances
freshmen who's that
Frances freshman a great reformer a
great progressive a person that would
never sit still what organized people
would get on with with changing the
public she was my grandma a great
influence tell us more about her
a woman that had a very hard life her
husband first husband died when when he
was he was very young she was very young
she had a couple of kids those days you
know you didn't have a lot of the social
insurance you have now she worked very
hard at a time when a lot of women
didn't go into the workforce but that
didn't stop her from doing a lot of
civic organizing whenever there were all
kinds of causes she was involved in and
when there wasn't an organization that
she could get involved in she created an
organization in fact I remember she used
to have a little house in the community
there were it was infested by bugs and
she started a Civic Association to get
people to pay money to get rid of the
bugs she had that kind of spirit and
that spunk a tough lady
where Childress admired her for it she
ended up living here in Washington up on
the lanyard place and many many years I
came to a visitor those were my first
recollections in Washington DC
the name rice and I know we talked just
briefly before we went on the air about
the pronunciation of it to people
butcher it all the time yes they do I I
think a lot of people use the German
pronunciation Reich but my ancestors
were Austrian it's a softer almost an
SCH rice sound I say to you before I
answer to anything except retch I draw
the line at retch but there is there is
a lot of butchering after Dartmouth and
Yale and Oxford and some of the
experiences we talked about in the
government when did you go to the John F
Kennedy School 1981 I started and I
didn't know very much about the Kennedy
School I knew that it would it taught
people who were interested in going into
government I had a pretty good record a
fairly small school I didn't know
whether I wanted to teach at a law
school or a business school I knew I
wanted to teach I had a lot of things I
wanted to write and I had a almost an
intuition that I would be a good teacher
but I took a chance I went to the
Kennedy School and I was very very
pleasantly surprised and delighted with
what I found very dedicated students
people coming there who easily could
have gone to business school or law
school but are fired up about public
service about public problems public
issues come there instead very committed
faculty people who again could easily be
an economics departments or in political
science
but are there at the Kennedy School
because they are fired up and concerned
about public issues one of the persons
you acknowledge in your and the preface
is martin peretz who is he
money parents is the publisher owner of
the New Republic and Marty's an old
friend I've been a contributing editor
on the New Republic for must be about 10
years now written a lot for them don't
always agree with their positions
particularly on foreign policy but
nevertheless respects the New Republic a
great deal the Atlantic right also for
the Atlantic more and more often
different kind of a magazine you can
write much longer pieces for the
Atlantic and the Whitworth Jack BT
people who I don't know if you know
these people this is sort of the Boston
crowd I don't know if I ever get down to
to Washington but very talented people
all these outlets and platforms that you
have if you could change the way we are
governed right now give us two or three
examples of what you would do if all of
a sudden president said Bob anything you
want I'll do I doubt that George Bush is
going to do that somehow Brian I've been
waiting my telephone is open he hasn't
called yet it seems to me and and this
gets back to one of the major themes of
the book that American corporations have
lost their linkage to the American
economy the competitiveness of America
no longer depends on the competitiveness
of American companies it depends on the
competitiveness of the American
workforce and we have a situation in
which the top 20 percent of American
workers by income are on an upward
escalator they're doing very well they
have good suburban schools good
four-year colleges like me they went to
law school or they went someplace else
they're doing fine we don't have to
worry about them are you calling them
the symbolic analysts I call them
symbolic analysts in the book because
they basically spend their lives their
working lives manipulating symbols
mathematical symbols if they're say
engineers verbal symbols maybe if
they're in journalism oral visual
symbols they are symbolic analysts in
the sense that they're conceptualizes
they're problem solvers and the world is
giving them a premium in return for
their valuable skills and valuable
talents are you a symbolic
analyst yourself I suppose I am I'm a
writer I'm a thinker I deal in symbols
the problem is that eighty percent of
the public is not on that upward
escalator eighty percent of the American
public is actually on a downward
escalator if you're a non supervisory
worker production worker most of these
people in the American economy right now
have a an income in real
inflation-adjusted terms nineteen ninety
one that is about what it was in
nineteen fifty-eight
the reason you have so many two income
families now is not because all these
opportunities for women but because
people women have to be in the workforce
now to make ends meet a lot of people
don't realize how much struggle is going
on American families are getting smaller
fewer kids not because they don't like
kids he can't afford kids two years ago
for the first time since the Second
World War the percentage of Americans
owning their homes went down the
percentage of Americans renting their
homes went up so you have two escalators
Brian you have a upward escalator of the
top twenty percent which by the way top
twenty percent brought home last year
more money in income than the bottom
eighty percent put together and then you
have a downward escalator so you have on
your way to becoming a two-track society
your question to me what would I do
about it with if Bush called me up
tomorrow I'd say look let's make
workforce training education preschool
let's make building the American
workforce the centerpiece of our
economic policy he hasn't done that one
of the other recommendations I remember
reading about was a progressive tax well
the question is how are you going to pay
for all of this now the minute I use the
T word a lot of people say I don't want
to listen to you but if we had a tax
that was as progressive as we had in
1978 now in 1978 very few people were
screaming that the American income tax
was too progressive if we had a tax that
was as progressive as we had it in 1978
last year the top 20% of Americans would
have paid about ninety six billion
dollars more in taxes than they in fact
paid you can do an awful lot with
education and training and investing in
the American workforce for ninety six
billion dollars a year when you have the
progressive tax though did
have all the tax loopholes I'm talking
about and this is with tax loopholes
figured in that is you know you
officially you had a tax rate that was
much higher than the effective rate of
1978 but even with the effective rate
the top 20% fact the top 10% weren't
paid ninety three billion dollars more
than they actually paid last year so
this is not a radical but people say
that I'm way over there and left no a
progressive income tax on the 1978
reducing military expenditures that's
another way of getting some money to
rebuild America when we start off you
said that a number of conservative
publications like your book they do and
it perplexes me and worries me because
if if I'm suddenly becoming an author
that the Wall Street Journal Fortune
magazine and some neoconservatives find
appetizing appealing then I must be
doing something wrong I have to go back
to my notes do you have any sense of why
they think it's a book worth reading
worth thinking about well I talked to
George Gilder the other day George is a
friend even though we see eye to eye on
absolutely nothing he is a
neoconservative he liked the book he
said because he thinks I correctly
analyzed the global economy the way
corporations and the global economy are
moving he didn't like my prescriptions
he didn't like my description of the top
20 percent at the bottom 80% but the
first half of the book he said was the
best thing he has ever read on the
emerging global economy let me pick out
a couple of companies that you mentioned
as a way of getting you to talk about
structure northern telecom northern
telecom a Canadian company that is
actually not really a Canadian company
it's it's making things all over the
world it's investing all over the world
it is becoming a global company you
mentioned that northern telecom was a
Canadian company with offices and
manufacturing facilities in the United
States and selling a lot here but also
Japanese are involved in how these are
involved how does that although it's
it's very hard to separate out any
longer who is US and who is them if you
want to buy an american-made car today a
year you have a better better
buying an american-made car if you buy a
Honda than buy a Pontiac LeMans most of
which is produced outside the United
States people forget or they don't
understand the extent to which
globalization has taken over these
corporations foreigners coming here
we're going there chrysler owns a big
chunk of mitsubishi ford owns 25% of
mazda where do you draw the line the
only thing that's left here in the
united states is the american workforce
regardless who they're working for I
don't care who they're working for you
you want to work for Fujitsu perfectly
fun if you're getting the training you
need if you're adding value to the world
economy Brian your real income is going
to be going up and you didn't mention
General Motors they own part of Isuzu
General Motors very close to Isuzu he
was part of Isuzu and again General
Motors made more money outside the
United States last year than inside the
United States these companies are very
very rapidly going global
well how does why does Lee Iacocca based
the Japanese in Lee Iacocca bashes the
job he doesn't he doesn't want to face
Japanese competition he would like to
have a wall around the United States he
owns part of but he owns part of
Mitsubishi and he uses a lot of parts
that are made in Japan he doesn't want
to talk about that
Lee Iacocca I think would like the
government to restrain Japanese imports
even more than they're restrained right
now but you know protectionism doesn't
get us anywhere this is where I part
company from a lot of my fellow
Democrats and liberals protectionism is
really like put it trying to put your
finger in a dike as the ocean is
changing you're not going to get
anywhere moreover you are costing
Americans a great deal of money you know
we protected the steel industry in the
United States after 1968 with this big
steel quota what happened to American
steel steel makers in the United States
after 1968 began investing less in
steelmaking technologies than they had
before 1968 because the heat was off in
fact steel makers began getting out of
steel a US Steel became US x with the X
being an indelible reminder that the
real purpose of that company is now
unknown and unknowable
well protectionism mmm has a multiplier
effect a lot of companies that depended
on Steel like auto companies in America
and appliance companies suddenly they
had to pay 40 percent
or for the steel they used then their
international competitors had to pay for
the steel they used and you have this
multiplier effect in terms of making
appliance of manufacturers and auto
manufacturers less and less competitive
page 143 by 1994 Japanese corporations
are expected to be contributing about 1
billion to American charities which will
compromise I'm sorry will comprise about
8% of the total corporate donations in
the United States Japanese are trying to
become good corporate citizens in
America American corporations would like
to be good corporate citizens abroad the
former chairman of IBM told me that IBM
has got to be a good corporate citizen
wherever it does business cannot be seen
to be playing favorites now that's an
important point cannot be seen to be
playing favorites so when it comes to
for example shutting down factories or
laying off workers IBM cannot you have
special preference to American workers
otherwise it runs into political
problems around the world wherever it
does business IBM is gradually ceasing
to become an American company are you
how do you feel about these global
corporations is it good for us or bad
for us well global capital is not a good
nor bad per se run I think it's part of
the emerging world economic order
capital itself money is sloshing across
borders we need Japanese money we need
German money and if they stopped
investing in us we'd really be in a
pickle the issue is not where the money
comes from the issue is not who's
corporation it is the issue is not who
the shareholders are the issue again I
sound like a broken record but I want to
emphasize this point the issue is what
are the values that Americans the skills
that Americans add to the world economy
how much a value do we actually add to
the world economy regardless of who were
working for in Madonna Bruce Springsteen
are they now under the control of the
Japanese no they're making a huge amount
of money Akio Morita is making them more
money than Larry Tisch ever made for
them got something I want to hold up
here and get a picture of it and we want
to leave the camera on there for just a
moment at first glance it struck me as
being humorous why did you do this and
what is it well I did it with
little bit of a twinkle in my eye these
are the kinds of jobs that symbolic
analysts often hold it's very difficult
to explain exactly what symbolic
analysts do if you are again one of
these people with an office in a steel
and glass tower in a major American city
you're a management consultant you're an
engineer you're a researcher a
strategist a planner you are probably
spending most of your days behind a
computer or you are in meetings you're
on the telephone what are you doing well
that little chart gives a an indication
of the kind of jobs you are under
undertaking you can you can like you can
be a communications management engineer
but a communications applications
adviser you can in other words you say
Kenny yeah take any title from the first
column add it to any title in the second
column and then add it to any title in
the third column and you get a title
that probably engages or involved
somebody in some sort of symbolic
analytic activity the higher status
symbolic analysts drop the last column
or drop the second column they usually
only have two words in their title like
applications planner or a development
director or management engineer well
these are jobs that they're difficult to
define because they are engaged
continuously in ideas and concepts and
problem solving very different from the
old manufacturing or even old service
economy we used to have even as late as
ten years ago is there going to be in
this country a permanent underclass but
we already have something of a permanent
underclass but we are also evolving a a
fairly permanent lower class and we're
evolving a fairly permanent overclass
we've talked about the underclass for
years and years and that is a problem
and we have to do things about that
problem and we're going to be living
with that problem for years and years so
it would be somebody in in the
underclass to define I'm talking right
underclass having long term poverty so
that I mean but basically long term
poverty how many how many people in our
country are in long-term poverty well we
know that one out of every five children
now is hungry and as we sit here Brian
one out of every five American children
is at this moment hungry is going to go
to bed tonight without a meal now that
for an advanced industrial nation that
prides itself on our standard of living
that is outrageous
if someone listen to this has a hungry
child is there some place for that
person to go get food for that job
sometimes there is some cities do have
shelters do have sort of voluntary soup
kitchens there are some points of light
there are not thousands of points of
light you know George Bush says that
there's all this volunteerism going on
it's not nearly that much in fact the
top 20% you look at their charitable
giving and you find that at least since
the 1986 tax revisions the top 20% have
cut way back on their charitable giving
it doesn't it's there's there are a few
tax advantages in that much charitable
giving in fact if you're at the top
chances are you're contributing a
smaller portion of your income then if
you're at the middle or bottom of the
income scale what's available again
let's say that there's a mother and a
father listening and and they want to
know is there enough government resource
available so apart from the soup
kitchens food stamps are being cut back
in fact during the 1980s they were cut
back about 15% many states know it's a
federal state program
matter what many states simply cannot
afford it so there are food stamps but
not nearly as much as there were before
if you have a poor kid who comes from a
poor family and wants to get some
preschool education maybe the family
needs some daycare and would like to
give the kid a little advantage the Head
Start program classic Great Society
program that works one program that we
know works
study after study after study shows that
if you take poor kids put them into a
headstart
they're going to have higher incomes and
more productive lives eventually out
there we're not funding it only half of
the kids that are eligible for headstart
are X have it accessible to them George
Bush is president he's sitting there
looking at these figures one in five
children you say are hungry do you think
he's watching this program Brian I hope
so I can't get to him he doesn't answer
my phone calls well let's say that he is
and and he's hearing this statistic that
one in five children go to bed
or whatever you want to use he looks
over at this column and sees that we
just spent seventy eighty billion
dollars on the war in the Gulf how do we
do that intellectually why wouldn't we
want to just say well we'll take twenty
five billion over here and spend it on
those folks that are hungry well first
of all there's this there is no domestic
policy that I can find in the Bush
administration I mean it's like Gertrude
Stein said about Oakland California
there's no there there
George Bush is a wonderful Secretary of
State it's one of the most effective
secretaries of state we've ever had I
think his foreign policy I may have some
differences with it but he's very
effective there's no doubt about what
happened in the Persian Gulf
he was effective but when it comes to
putting our energies into rebuilding
this nation I'm not just talking about
the underclass I'm talking about the
middle class the lower middle class the
working class all of these people on the
downward escalator we're also talking
about infrastructure the potholes
bridges we haven't built a new airport
in this country since 1974 every other
factor of production is mobile if we
want to build the economy we've got to
pay attention to human capital and
infrastructure but it's not happening
the federal government is getting out of
the business back to the hungry thing
you're Tom Foley and George Mitchell
watching this and they're sitting there
thinking about the figures why wouldn't
they get together pass a bill to spend
the money on hungry children because
they would probably say the new budget
deficit agreement with the White House
makes it almost impossible for us to
increase domestic discretionary spending
without taking the money out from other
programs for the disadvantaged and we
don't want to do that we have put
ourselves in a straitjacket Brian
there's absolutely no way under the new
agreements that we can spend more money
in ways that we need to spend it now the
next question would be well why don't we
change the agreement why don't we have
an entirely different budget structure
yes I think we should I think Democrats
ought to be saying look going into debt
to the rest of the world is not such a
bad thing if we are spending that
indebtedness on investments in our
future if we're spending it on education
training infrastructure if we're
building up our capacity to be more
productive in the future that's good
debt it's not banded in the 19th century
we as a nation we're much more indebted
as a percentage of gross national
product to foreigners and we are today
but in those days we invested those in
Dedham canals railroads bridges
factories we are not investing that's
the problem
not debt it's lack of public and private
investment go back to the hungry kids if
there are really one in five hungry kids
how come there aren't more outraged
politicians across the spectrum we don't
hear them we don't hear people making
lots of speeches about it why it
wouldn't this be an emergency well I
think it is emergency why aren't they
that some of them are talking about it
remember half of Americans don't vote
and the half that doesn't vote are the
people that are at the lowest point on
that escalator that is there's a direct
correlation between political activism
and how much money you have is the top
20% is very active politically they vote
and they also make a lot of campaign
contributions and they finance PACs and
they do a lot of things half of
Americans do not vote a lot of
politicians these days why should they
listen to people that don't vote it's a
callous and cynical thing to say I hope
that our politicians would listen to
even the people that don't vote and to
some extent they do but if there there's
no political activism if there's no
participation by the bottom half then
they're not going to be listened to how
would you take care of those kids that
are hungry specifically well I don't
think there's any I mean with regard to
one out of every five kids there's no
great secret about about how to handle
how to handle hunger I mean by golly we
do have a food stamp program we do have
ways of dealing with hunger quite
directly we have famine relief programs
all over the world it is an emergency
I'll give you another frightening
statistic infant mortality in this
country we trail 18 other nations in our
level of infant mortality we have the
the 19th level of information other
nations are better than we are
have a lower level of infant mortality
we have in some of our central cities it
levels of infant mortality like the
third world
Brian the top 20 percent what's
happening and it's happening gradually I
don't mean to indict the top 20% but
what's happening is the top 20% are in
effect seceding from the rest of the
country many of them living in nice
suburbs with their own school systems
surrounding themselves with security
guards
good parks and recreation private health
clubs they are not connected in ways
that they were before we are segregating
by income as a nation more than we've
ever segregated before is zip code
marketing is all the rage
why because marketers now know that the
best way of a finding affluent people is
to target certain communities those are
good schools but kids have all the
brakes the bottom 80% are on a different
track the political issue over the next
10 or even 20 years is how can we get
the top 20% to make investments in the
future productivity of the bottom 80 you
teach kids young people you talk lecture
right let's say a kid comes up to you
young student comes up to you stand in
the train station over here and says
professor right I get it you know my
acute is fairly high my parents don't
have anything I don't you know I don't
know how to get ahead what would you
tell a young person 16 17 years old how
can they get ready for school and then a
professional well I probably say look if
you were very poor I mean really very
very poor and your family's very very
poor and your did very well in high
school
chances are you can get a scholarship to
college if you were middle class lower
middle class working class you didn't do
great in high school you're gonna have
trouble getting to college college costs
have increased in inflation-adjusted
terms about 26% over the 1980s the
federal government has pulled a plug on
college grants on college loans and
college aid well what are you gonna do I
would say to that kid if you can't get a
loan if you can't finance college at
least get the technical training that
you need to set you on a channel for
lifelong learning and some in some trade
in some technical area of competence
unfortunately I would say the kid we
don't have an apprenticeship program
like they have in the former West
Germany we don't have a public-private
partnership to make sure that you get
you can get skills designed to put you
in touch with particular jobs but by all
means do whatever you can to get those
skills and when you get a job make sure
it's the kind of job that's going to
build your skills
not just a job that's going to be
automated over the next ten years this
book you have the works of Nations
preparing ourselves for 21st century
capitalism what line of work would you
go into if you were a young person today
to get ready for 20 the 21st century how
were young for a person today I would
try to get along the lines we've been
talking before the best education in the
building blocks of symbolic analytic
thinking problem solving problem
identifying a good liberal arts
education there's no substitute no
substitute for a good liberal arts
education if you can go there if you can
afford it
because that does build a foundation
stones for lifelong learning also
communication skills are very important
not just the analytic skills not just
being good with with a computer or with
a pencil paper you need to communicate
you're going to be making presentations
you're going to be cooperating with
other people you're gonna be working in
teams learn how to work in teams a lot
of the American educational system is
now premise taun individual performance
but that's not the working life you're
going to lead in the future gonna have
to work with people Harvard has a five
billion dollar endowment what the
largest in the world or at least the
largest amount of states do you think
it's doing enough as a university for
the people that aren't so well I know I
don't I don't think any university is
doing enough I I'm a trustee at another
University I think that there are all
kinds of things that American higher
education ought to be doing could be
doing working with the American business
community in fact American business is
not doing enough Ryan a lot of American
corporate chief executive officers every
time I go to a conference on American
competitiveness and there are many in
fact the conference industry on American
competitiveness is one of the most
competitive industries in America every
time I go to one of those conferences
there's a chief executive officer that
says by golly I care about the American
school systems we are engaging in a
partnership with American schools we are
we are funding computers and we're doing
this in that baloney American
corporations are pulling out more money
from local school districts than they
ever put in their playing school
district off against school history
they're saying essentially to any town
whether
do business look if you don't give us a
tax abatements we're gonna go to the
next town that will give us a tax cut
and as a result a lot of towns don't
have the money they need to finance a
decent a decent Elementary School in
these decent high school in 1960 44% of
local property taxes much of which
financed schools came from American
corporations 1991 were down to 16% so
all of these corporate ceos that are
talking in a good game of their about
American education they're pulling money
out of American education what would you
do then if you're running one of those
corporations would you say I'd rather
pay more tax no I would work with other
business leaders I'd say look we have we
have an obligation a social obligation
we have an economic obligation we are
Americans after all let's all get
together we're not going to have this
war between the states or between the
cities for tax abatements we're gonna
have a national truce we're not going to
threaten local towns we're not going to
try to get the best deal we can we are
going to say to the local tax
jurisdictions you have a responsibility
you have responsibility we're going to
help you fulfill that responsibility to
provide the best education possible for
those kids what do you think of this
deficit is it something to worry about
if you were in charge again would you
get rid of it I don't think the deficit
per se is something to worry about again
the issue is what we do with the
borrowings not whether we borrow we have
not been investing those borrowings
public sector or private sector I have
no patience with people that say we've
got to simply reduce the deficit for the
sake of reducing the deficit what
difference does that make
any businessperson knows that you borrow
money for the sake of investing in the
future of your business those are wise
borrowings because then you can pay
those debts off when you get bigger a
national economy works in exactly the
same way it doesn't matter that we're
borrowing money if we were investing
those monies that we borrowed from
abroad in education training
infrastructure of factories but we're
not who's got the power and economics in
this town in your opinion what jobs
really pull the levers well
basically in this town right now there's
only one game and that is the Federal
Reserve Board
it's Alan Greenspan and his crew over
there primarily because there's no
longer a fiscal policy to speak of again
we've hamstrung ourselves we've created
this new budget agreement you can't do
anything with fiscal policy we can't try
to get out of this recession by
stimulating public expenditures because
basically we're hamstrung so it all
belongs with the Federal Reserve and
that's too much responsibility for the
Federal Reserve Board Alan Greenspan is
trying to stimulate the economy it's
like pushing on a wet noodle there's not
enough demand in the system American
corporations are laden with debt
American consumers are laden with that
the spending is not coming forth exports
we can't rely on exports Europe is in a
recession East Asia is going into a
recession
I think this recession by the way is
going to last much longer than a lot of
people now claim but getting back to
your question economic policy no it's
not here in Washington
it's a Federal Reserve Board it's not in
the executive branch it's not in
Congress somebody said we're gonna make
you chairman of the Federal Reserve
would that be an exciting position to be
in
not for me I don't find it very
thrilling to look at figures about the
money supply some people do if you're
into macroeconomics if you if you want
to maintain steady growth and I think
that money supply is important for
steady growth then that would be a very
good job but I'm looking at the
structure of the American economy Ron
I'm looking beyond the current recession
even when we get out of the current
recession the structural problems that
I've been talking about that two-tiered
economy that we're creating with a top
20% but most Americans on a downward
tilt that to me is much more important
over the long term do you think that
given your view of how this town
operates that it will ever change and
that four-fifths that are going down
will ever start back up well if I didn't
think there was a possibility for change
I wouldn't write my books I wouldn't be
here today obviously
deep in my heart I'm a cockeyed optimist
why am i optimistic everybody says to me
you know I've read your book I don't see
why you're optimistic the top 20% are
linking up with a global economy doing
better and better
putting themselves in these economic
unclaimed separate from the rest of them
of society and if they have all the
money and they're not willing to invest
in the rest of America why rush are you
so optimistic well when I say back to
them is is this that ultimately I'm a
student of American history not only
American economics and politics if you
look back in American history this
country has an extraordinary ability and
willingness to roll up its sleeves and
get on with what has to be done when
they understand stand the nature of the
problem first world war depression
second world war we do it we ultimately
do it there's a feeling of affinity not
only when we fight Foreign Wars you know
all the yellow ribbons all the good
feeling all the self-confidence I think
we can turn that toward rebuilding
America with the right kind of
leadership after the Second World War
remember we rebuild Europe we rebuild
Japan why can't we rebuild America you
sit in Boston and say if we could only
get X elected this thing would change
well I've been involved in a number of
presidential campaigns all of them
unsuccessful in fact if I were a
presidential candidate I'd avoid me like
the plague
because obviously I do something wrong
there are some very attractive
candidates out there for the Democrats
many of them have not yet put up their
hand and said I'd like to be a candidate
everybody's scared off now without
popularity ratings that George Bush has
the Democrats have not displayed a great
deal of intestinal fortitude of late and
maybe I can't blame them when you have a
president with 90 percent popularity but
there are terrific people out there
who's the best economic thinker in your
opinion among politicians well I among
my favorites is a guy named Bill Clinton
the governor of Arkansas he's a dear and
old friend we were at Oxford together
I've looked what he's done in Arkansas
with Arkansas education he's done
exactly the right thing with very
limited resources and he's the kind of
talented guy I think we need right at
the top the cabro provide the right kind
of leadership anybody else I like Al
Gore I think he's also extraordinarily
talented I used he's level-headed he's
been saying many of the same things not
in as much detail or maybe I should say
he's been influenced by me maybe
hopefully
I'm very impressed with him as well I've
worked for a number of years with other
Democrats on the hill there are other
governor's around they're very very
impressive another senator that I like
very much I don't know him very well but
I like what he's done so far as Bob
Kerrey
I think he could be a very attractive
candidate for a number of reasons would
you advise an Al Gore about Kerry or
Bill Clinton to jump in the race for
1992 I would I would and I would for the
simple reason that even if you don't
have a a prayers chance of winning at
least in 1992 you can help set the
national agenda for 1996 you can
establish credibility for yourself you
make a respectable showing but also you
alert the American public to what you
stand for and so by the time 1996 rolls
around even if you don't do very well in
92 you already have the beginnings of a
movement it's all about education you
know I go back to my role as an educator
I think politics is very much about
education to the American population is
many people are very confused about
economics and about college they don't
know what's happening Japanese are
coming here they're concerned about that
they're losing their jobs a lot of
economic insecurity
well the obligation of people like me
college professors but also the
obligation of people in politics is to
help educate the public alert them to
reality not to pull the wool over their
eyes not to simply say don't worry be
happy' but to alert them to reality how
much do you teach I teach a lot how many
hours a week well I teach let's see in
the fall I teach two big courses one
course has a better hundred and twenty
students another course remember these
graduate students now the course has a
last fall about 6070 students in the
spring I teach this spring I I have it
easy I have a little seminar because I
knew the book was coming out and I
wanted I wanted the the intimate cannot
contact that you get in a seminar and I
wanted to talk about many of the themes
in this book
I don't mind teaching big classes I'm
like big classes I don't like lecturing
I never lecture I try to say make the
class into an arena of discussion I try
to provoke dissent in the class I want
people to take sometimes there's
simulations they take different roles
have different characters and politics
and economics
I want the classroom to be alive
exciting any way to characterize today's
students in your classes well remember
my students at the John F Kennedy School
of Government our self selected group
these are people who could have gone to
law school or Business School
but went to the Kennedy School at
Harvard because they're committed to
public service so this is not a
representative cross sample of America's
students I'm very fortunate I'm very
fortunate now I have in the past taught
in a law school in fact I've taught a
few courses at Harvard Law School I've
taught at American University Law School
here in Washington a lot of students in
law school obviously are very
career-oriented that's why they're there
they want to make a lot of money
Business School is exactly the same way
one concern I have is that so many
bright American kids want to go into law
and Investment Banking you know the pie
slicing professions instead of the pie
and larger professions and that is a
problem for the country it continues to
be a problem what's the most popular
lecture that you give in any and anyone
here well again I don't give lectures
ever I give I I don't well I try not to
give lecture in classrooms I don't know
why I give a lecture
you know kids can be a lecture is a
medieval institution you know if you if
you if you have lecture notes why not
just Xerox the notes and give them to
students what's the most engaging topic
then what what is it what hour is it did
you walk out and say again I'll tell you
brothers I love my classes I love tea
tree in fact the exception is when I
walk out of a classroom saying I didn't
have fun I don't think anything happened
in that classroom I teach courses on
political economy I teach courses on
management in the public sector and
leadership in the public sector a lot of
them our case classes that is that we
examine a particular case of somebody
trying to grapple with a political
economic or leadership issue and if I
can get those students excited upset
provocation intellectual provocations
what I do in this book I'm an
intellectual provocateur that's my role
anyway to define the politics of your
students today and know a lot of people
look at
and they immediately assume liberal but
no that's totally simplistic I have a
lot of people who most people would say
are extreme right-wingers a lot of
international students who fall not
quite on the American political spectrum
at all
I think these old ideological
compartments are meaning less and less
frankly but the common denominator of my
students is a commitment to make the
world better make public policy better
make public service mean something at a
time this is what the book looks like
the work of nations by robert rice
professor at the John F Kennedy School
at Harvard thank you for being with us
thank you Brian